i carlos akan
will prove to you
that any triangle that you draw is
equilateral that means it has the same
length of the sides all around so i'm
starting with three intersecting lines
and a second one here
and a third one here and i mark the
intersection vertices as the vertices of
a triangle a b and c that does not look
you know equilateral not too far off but
it's certainly arbitrarily drawn now i'm
taking the middle point of the side bc i
call this m and i draw
the perpendicular bisector so i'm
drawing a line that's perpendicular
coming out of m going off in a
particular direction and of course we
have a right angle here now you know
that this line is the locus of all the
points
that are equidistant from point b
and from point c i'm going to draw
another extra line and that is the angle
bisector
coming out of a here so that should look
something like that i guess
and this line of course let's call it
angle divider d is the locus of all the
points that are equidistant from lines a
b
and from line ac
so if i'm going to the intersection
point between those two lines which is
about here which i'm calling x then i
know that this point is equal distance
from b and from c because it lies on the
perpendicular bisector so let's draw
these two lines and we know that these
are equal because we're on the
perpendicular bisector okay but also if
i draw the shortest distance from x to
line a b
which might look something like that and
comes in of course at the right angle
here and i draw the shortest distance
from x onto line ac and has a right
angle here let's call this point b star
and let's call this point c star then i
know that x b star is equal to x c star
because we're on the angle bisector
and these are all the points that
equidistance from those two lines okay
now we focus on
these two small triangles and here we
have a triangle with a right angle
adjacent to the right angle we have this
double marked line x b star and here we
have a right angle and adjacent to the
right angle we have this double marked
line x c star
and we know these two lines are the same
length we also have the
third side of the triangle which is
opposite of the right angle marked with
this one slash and it's the same as this
slash over here that's the hypotenuse in
this case and so because two triangles
then they have two equal sides and
they have the longer side being upper
side to an angle that also happens to be
equal then these two
triangles are congruent as a matter of
fact in this case you can see they're
basically mirror images of one another
now this of course tells us that
we also now know that b
b star
then must be equal to
c
c star b b star market was three slashes
equal to c
c star now we have more congruent
triangles we also have the triangle
a
x
b star
being a mirror image of a x
c star
and so those two triangles are congruent
and this of course tells us
that a b star
equals
to
a c star okay now what can we conclude
from all that well we can say that
a b star
minus b b star is really just the side a
b and we can say that a c star minus c c
star is just the side a c now we're
almost there we have proven up here that
a b star is equal to a c star we have
proven that b b star is equal to c c
star okay and so these two sides being
equal it essentially then follows that a
b
equals a c
so we have done nothing special about
the triangle and we have now proven that
these two sides are of equal length so
we've got an isosceles triangle that's
right
and now of course i can go around and do
exactly the same construction on two
other sides
making this what was a before and
proving that
these two sides are the same it's the
same construction hanging off to this
side i don't have to do it a third time
because once i've proven that i can
really show that all sides of this
triangle are of equal length i can just
start from another vertex draw my angle
bisector
do my perpendicular bisector over there
and do exactly the same construction so
you of course know that this cannot
possibly be true
and so i encourage you to go very
carefully step by step through here
and try to find out you know where is
that one bogus step so be vigilant go
for it